[Music]
hey guys it is the Monday after the
Oscars which means we're tired and I
have not washed my hair yet but we're
coming to you live here for the daily
duty to give you guys a recap and a
little breakdown of last night's Oscars
the Academy Awards thankfully I have
some help today
we got lauren zima here who is also
stood her hair and makeup from last
night she was on the red carpet
literally haven't washed a thing all the
deets on all the looks and all the
fashion wearing me talking about
speaking of fashion don't you love how
comfy cozy we are we are also not watch
this yes guys we are Oscars hungover and
we want to thank you for being here with
us because we're exhausted I think
between the three of us we have one
functioning brain there was an option to
do the high stools and maybe dress up a
little bit I'm coming on if I can sit on
a couch Thank You Danny yup it's the end
of award season the end of the Oscars
means the end of everything to say that
means a long-long award season for us
but you know what the what a way to go
out though the Academy Lord Awards were
last night super fun they looked a lot
better than we do right now and so let's
get right into it with the fashion and
of course guys fashion is subjective
there are so many people who looked
amazing last night we can't get to all
this so if you have any favorites any
best-dressed looks of the red carpet
please let us know we'll get them to
this iPad right here but katie has some
pics we're gonna kick off yeah let's
start with Nicole Kidman she's wearing
Armani Prive it's this bold blue
plunging neckline delicate romantic
giant bow on the waistline she is a huge
slit right up the middle the hair is
sleek the makeup is subtle and perfect
she just looks amazing Nicole Kidman
knows how to do a red crap and say I'm
like ladies and gentlemen that is a
movie star yeah she always turns out
some really amazing red carpet looks but
I just feel like she knows what she's
dressing for and that's how you're
supposed to show up to the Oscars
today's how're you guys on the red
carpet she was the one actor or actress
I saw there's all those fans in the
stands yeah everybody waves she went up
to people shook hands said
hello saint-like she is also that kind
of a person and it really just made her
glow her look was beautiful but that
energy she radiates I think that's part
of her being such a best dress moment is
that she glows because she knows how to
carry herself and whatever she's wearing
like she was floating down there I think
that's why she's also such an a-lister I
think that's what makes her a mega movie
stars the fact she is nice to fans she
was one of the last to show up and she
still made the effort to go and speak to
people his fans who waited there all day
absolutely I saw her take some selfies
with the fans there but also if you
checked her Instagram on her way to get
her hair makeup done she rolled down her
window to one of those like start or
vans yeah like just touring on the
tourist tour in Hollywood she was like
oh I would freak we need more coffee
okay let's let's move on to Margot
Robbie
she was announced as the new ambassador
for Chanel so of course she's wearing
Chanel Haute Couture mm-hmm this
incredibly exquisite white dress that
was custom made by Chanel by Karl
Lagerfeld it took over 550 hours and
seven people helping Karl to make this
dress and you'll see like the garland
draping off her her arms and then the 3d
garland it like covers over the the
corset bodice area her hair her makeup I
think she was my best dressed of the
night I love Nicole chemists with Aussie
versus Aussie yeah okay I'm gonna go
into my best dressed of the night Jane
Fonda a big trend last night white was a
big trend and you guys this woman I saw
her in person she was also someone who
was just radiating from the inside out
glowing she had a time's up pin on that
gorgeous white ball Mon dress and I love
that Jane Fonda I mean I think the
woman's either almost 80 years old or in
her 80s rocking the ball Mon you know
what I mean like she doesn't mess around
and can we talk about how okay for
example go back to the Emmys remember
she wore that like fierce long ponytail
I was inspired by Gwen Stefani and then
tonight she's like balm on crops too
Jane has fun with it and that's what I
love about her
has so much life in her and she also was
fearless when it comes to her fashion
yes you know another woman of a certain
age who also crushed the red carpet is
my new spirit animal Rita Moreno guys
she arena Mareno she recycled these same
Oscars dress from when she won her Oscar
for Best Supporting Actress in 1962 she
said she let it in a little bit but take
a look at this you guys she recreated
the bodice ah excuse me it's actually
the same dress she just changed up the
the alterations a little bit but it's
the original one from years ago when she
went for West Side Story what a moment I
thought was very fitting for the 90th
Oscars for her to do that and pay homage
to that on we caught up with her on the
red carpet et's Kevin Frazier Nancy
O'Dell got the scoop on how I love it
she was amazing if you guys watch the
Oscar she was the one sipping champagne
made that grand entrance it was
incredible she also told Kevin and Nancy
that she kept the dress obviously and
every once in a while she'll go in the
closet and just graze it oh and now
she's got to wear it again
it's also just a self-deprecating loving
her moment loved it you guys your
comments are coming in green apple ad it
says yes for Jane Fonda yes yes yes for
Jane Fonda again we are going over our
best-dressed of the night so we want to
know what you guys think let us know who
you thought was the best-dressed or what
looks you things might have missed the
mark cuz we could have all of our lists
up Aditi I am calm and talk in her
favorite spirits right and it's not just
about the women the moon also turned it
out and last night none other than
Timothy Xiaomei really turned out with
this amazing amazing Berluti tux also in
all white the trend last night you guys
he's a fashion icon at his young young
age how old is he he's 22 and if we
to talk about spirit animal it has been
so fun to watch him go through this
award season to just have fun with it
like he's you know instagramming and
from of the Oscars and just bringing
that youthfulness to it happy to be
there told us that he was just you know
stoked to see all the people have to say
he had a way of turning a entirely white
tux into something very young and hip I
think the black moto like boots really
helped contrast oh it was amazing
machine
and honestly Timothy shell knew who was
nominated for his first Oscar and he's
also the youngest Oscar nominee this
year him at the Oscars would be like me
at the Oscars he busts it on his phone
inside the ceremony giving us an inside
look of what it's like to be sitting
there as a nominee in the it look
there's his co-star Armie Hammer holding
a couple Oscars with Wonder Woman um he
also gave us this look that you guys
might have missed on TV it's the rest of
the best actress nominees hugging
together embracing after Frances
McDormand emotional fiery speech so um
Timothy breaking I think Academy
regulation by if there's somebody who
the Academy is not going to come after
ya another young star
zendaya looking absolutely flawless in
this Jean Bautista Valley gown it's
one-shoulder its chocolate colored it's
chiffon
I love the top fun she has really
emerged as one of the fashion icons to
watch in my opinion no 100% she always
brings a different look to the guests
whether she's changing up her hair going
for a totally different style
I'm interviewer about interviewed her
about it before and she's like you know
sometimes I make the decision day of I
really just don't take it too seriously
and I run with it it works for her yeah
you know what she has an amazing stylist
behind her helping her make these
decisions her status is la Roache he's
really well-known in the fashion
industry and he did not only just dress
zendaya but he also dressed two-time
Oscar nominee mary j blige this was her
first look of the night on the red
carpet in this amazing custom Versace
number it's white it's it's bedazzled
the bodice on it just fits MJB
like a freakin glove she had three looks
of the night that's the first one but
you know it was a big night for her her
first time at the Oscars and she turned
she showed up and turned out those
earrings come on liars love the way it
fits her
and the combination of the bling mixed
in with that really Sheen shininess of
the fabric
it was totally totally sunny and you
know what I love when people have a
little train at the Oscars you can work
that train at the Oscars that's what
Bruno and cardi would call dripping in
another star who showed up in Versace is
Jennifer Garner and when she showed up
my jaw literally dropped I've never seen
Jen Garner look this incredible on a red
carpet I mean the color the fit the hair
the makeup the earrings I mean you guys
I want a series on this amazing saying
okay here's the thing
yes we were blown away by her she's in
this bright bold blue color yeah and
what we had all been noticing is we get
all these paparazzi photos and as you
know over the past I guess it's been
well over a year now since her and Ben
Affleck broke up Jen we saw her you know
obviously she's going through a tough
time she's like at the farmers market
she's in a sweater like she's just
trying to push through and then we saw
Jen coming out of her workouts okay then
we start getting pictures of her out of
her workouts then I find out a good
friend of mine who is nutritionist too
many stars
Kelly Levesque if you do not follow her
in social media check her out she now
has Jen garner as a client and now here
we go Jen garner at the Oscars looking
amazing
you have to prep em out of tank yeah
like the Oscars are four months away I'm
gonna start getting my revenge bod back
now that and she has a movie coming out
like this is Jen's time to shot I really
think we were witnessing the first page
of Jen's next chap yeah if I may say I
thought her makeup looked amazing oh
that it fit her body beautifully and you
know she is one of those women who
especially like she's always talked
about how important it is for her to be
a mom to spend time at home with her
kids but then she really used this
moment to like glam out and wow
everybody and say this is my sexy side
and I love that I don't have a front
runner for Best Dressed because Deb lisa
connie and nicole all agree with you
guys they love although we have some
love to be beside loved mary j blige she
looked incredible and kim was diggin
zendaya
looking at amazing yes by the way here's
also how I kind of know when somebody's
best dressed
mother calls me my mom Donna called me
and said Jennifer Garner looked amazing
yes so many people out there quote
looking horrible
Jennifer Carney looked amazing like
right mom well it took the Academy
Awards to get out of those sweats and
we're glad you did it dad you did it
someone else was also out of sweats
alton allison janney you guys can I just
say this woman has had a great time with
award season and she capped it off last
night by winning an Oscar she has swept
the Best Supporting Actress categories
and all these awards shows and she
killed in her outfit lady in red looking
stunning and Reem Acra and can I just
tell you guys I don't know if you can
notice it but she had diamonds head to
toe if you look closely like every part
of her body and she told me she was
wearing a quite a big amount of money in
diamonds here's what she had to say oh
it's crazy these are forever a mark
diamonds this is like a 10 carat diamond
ring and this necklace is I'm blind
she's correct because the press release
that we received said over 4 million
dollars worth of diamonds on her last
[Laughter]
ability I know you know well sometimes
they really give an eye I didn't ask her
if they do but sometimes they give you a
security person with you when you're
wearing that much in diamonds that these
awards shows and so you guys you see
that big rock on her finger of course I
had to say a Alison are you engaged or
what's going on here and she had the
best answer she goes I am engaged to
myself as a woman in my career and I
said yes and that she was having a
career moment yes for Alison absolutely
stunning last night and just somebody
who everybody in Hollywood loves how do
you forget how many people she's worked
with I'm like what's this award season
been like for you she said that laura
dern invited a bunch of the nominees for
private dinner a few days earlier and
they just had like a small fun private
dinner she's like I saw Marilyn like
Meryl Streep and she said we I mean I've
worked with her and she has it's just
like everybody I think was so happy to
see her have her which is why I was
funny that's the begin
her speech when she was she was like and
I did it all by myself she was cracking
us up all night long we also talked to
her at the after party and you guys have
to hear where she told Cameron Mathison
she's gonna be keeping her Oscar I just
want to say a big congratulations and
I'm thinking and I know you've got the
Emmys and the other awards for this
incredible season where is this one get
a special spot on the show no shelf
release on my night I mean I want to
look at it for a while when I wake up
and be happy for myself and proud of
what what happened I'm sure whatever
Wolfgang makes all lately she's engaged
to that yes the honesty the candidness I
am so obsessed with her yes we want to
wrap down our best dress you guys with
Oh somebody who was just loving the
night Jennifer Lawrence looking stunning
in Christian Dior of course I thought
Katie you mentioned white was a big
trend I thought that sparkles inviting
more another another big trend yeah she
looks great and you know not a nominee
not a winner last night she was there to
present with Jodie Foster and she was
just I think I like seeing her loose
like this you know she didn't have that
pressure she was just like I'm looking
sexy out here and having a good time I
was gonna say the thing about the Oscars
is sometimes people fashion wise either
play it really save or like too elegant
she had fun you know she's there to have
a good time she's not nominee she's just
presenting and let me tell you guys who
she wasn't even her best eight five last
night I mean from the red carpet when
the minute she arrived just like arms
out ready to go there she is right there
and look at the guy behind ya live your
truth I mean she really did come have a
good time and what you didn't see on TV
was Jenna was thirsty right before the
ceremony she got to her seat early but
she also wanted to climb over to get to
it with a drink in hand guys that is
hopefully a soft blonde I don't know but
that's her and her custom - you are
walking over to get to her I'm so glad
she didn't trip and fall and look at
she's like during that that is my seat
right there you are do you think I was
gonna sit here and not drink
maril having a moment
uh I mean JLo has been on a press tour
for red Sparrow and she admitted to a
lot of talk shows that she the only way
she gets through it is through booze she
said it yeah like she don't mean she's
been drinking a lot on this press tour
and I think like the Oscars was that
finish line for her you know I do think
she's never looked better than between
the red Sparrow press tour last night
yes her looks have just been on point
through and through and you know what I
love seeing those silly moments because
I think everybody talks like oh the
Globes or this party awards show I like
seeing those fun moments to be honest
you the Oscars are fun there is alcohol
at the Oscar you know what if there's
alcohol JLo is drinking it yes and by
the way more comments coming in from you
guys Frankie says Meryl Streep and
Allison Janney were stunning both ladies
in red agree they were gorgeous and a
lot of people still can't stop talking
about Jen garner oh yes the coming of
Jennifer Garner yes I love this I want
to get into some other stuff you guys
might have missed or that they didn't
show on TV um what's trending today is
that Francis McDormand
Oscar was stolen last night that's right
you guys are as crazy as that sounds
et can't confirm that a man actually
swiped Francis McDormand Oscar she went
for Best Actress for three billboards
outside of Abbey Missouri someone swiped
her from her table at the Governor's
Ball does that who does that who was a
person who was able to get into that
party yeah just deals that and what do
you think you're not gonna get caught
remember that booze that what you said
was flowing I have a feeling that has
something to do with that but we can't
confirm that but we can confirm is that
that man end up being arrested and
booked crazy but a rep confirmed to et
last night that the Oscar is back in
Francis possession in fact last night
they told us they are happily reunited
and are enjoying an in-and-out burger
together you guys I still have so many
great lessons like does this mean that
this man I mean was he really trying to
steal it to be pick it up and forget to
put it back was he using it to go party
hopping because you can get into other
parties if you show your Oscar I think
if you're not that well-known if that
was part of it do you think he was a
Wolfgang Puck chocolate like a baby
makes shapes office
no it is I will say you guys it's kind
of crazy to see the security at the
Oscars because I was there and you know
you you have to go through you have to
of course show your credential and like
I mean they have scanners like machines
to make sure nobody's getting anything
through so there's a lot of Oscars a lot
of police on hands so I'm not surprised
the person was caught and I guess we'll
see what happens we'll see what happens
but she's got to back in her possession
um you guys a huge winner last night
that had everybody buzz and of course
was Jordan Peele who became the first
African American to win for a Best
Original Screenplay or get out which was
one of my yeah that's right yeah and
they did last night as well what was
amazing that was his interview backstage
in the press room he talked to the press
about why this award in the moment he
had last night was much bigger than him
take a look when the nominations for
this came together first of all when the
nominations came out I had this amazing
feeling of looking at the the 12 year
old that had this burning in my guts for
this type of validation and I it
instantly I instantly realized that an
award like this is much bigger than me
this is about paying it forward to the
young people who might not believe that
they could achieve the highest honor in
whatever craft they want to push forward
I just want that what a guy I love that
because I think he was really taken
aback by the fact that he won an Oscar I
mean we're talking about a guy who came
from Comedy Central I don't think in a
million years he thought this could
happen for himself cuz this is the guy
who do did Keanu lost I mean in such a
historic moment and I loved what he said
about the young people because it's
something Guillermo del Toro said in his
speech for best picture as well you know
he he dedicated to those people those
aspiring filmmakers who are gonna lead
us into the future beyond entertainment
you know so I thought that was a really
special moment you mentioned we
mentioned Comedy Central of course
Jordan is one half of Key & Peele
what we found is counterpart mr. mr.
Keegan Mike you actually caught up with
keegan-michael key at the Vanity Fair
party to get his reaction to his boy
Jordan win in that Oscar take a look
I think I jumped up on a chair any
screams I jump up on a chair and
screamed for about 30 seconds so sweet I
love I love that I'm moving right along
guys to another time oh stop oh come on
like we said the night was the 90th
Oscars and it was a night of people
addressing the time's up movement the
dreamers the
is so many issues and one is she was
comically addressed of course you guys
remember the hashtag Oscars so white
well Tiffany Haddish and Maya Rudolph
decided to tackle that by joking that
nobody needed to worry just because the
two of them were on stage didn't mean
that the Oscars would become so black
they were hilarious they had so many
great jokes up there we are literally
like can you guys please host these
matters these two would be epic Larry
wants him to run for office I know and
like I'm here for it
I'm also want to point out that my or
the Tiffany Haddish recycled her dress
from SNL you guys this is the dress that
she said hey I bought this dress myself
I spent the money on it I'm gonna get my
use out of it white was on trend anyway
Tiffany Haddish onstage as a presenter
at the Oscars wore a dress she'd worn on
us and I loved it and she weren't super
hugs I wore the matter
Tiffany you guys heard Maya went out
there in their slippers and that's why
I'm wearing these yes
loved it we had so much fun with Tiffany
we talked to her on the red carpet
before the show and at the Governor's
Ball afterwards and she talked about how
hey yeah she's got to make that money
here's what she said to our own Cameron
Mathison what about if they asked you to
host next year at the Oscars I would
totally do it if we get paid because I
didn't get paid for that so but if I get
paid you need to get like sag minimal no
I get nothing so but you know if I get
paid I'm down because you know I got it
I got bills to pay
okay dresses you hear that agents gotta
I gotta pay for those dresses she's
before him again are you guys Terry
really was
the belle of the ball yeah at the Oscars
and she was making her rounds at all the
after parties including a very exclusive
one jay-z and Beyonce who got the Oscar
after-party game last night they threw
one at the Chateau Marmont for their
girl mary j blige you say that again
Tomomi yep oh man I can't speak English
today but I could speak no so yeah jay-z
Beyonce through this exclusive
after-party only a hundred and fifty
guests were invited to this it was for
mary j blige Tiffany did scored invite
despite having to sign the NDA you guys
remember Beyonce called her out in that
new song top off we talked to Tiffany
about who was so stuck still stoked that
Beyonce called her out no I know but
it's up on our site at ET online.com you
guys go check that out and i said saw
and if you're in the TV game that means
sound on tape by the way so many
comments coming in from you guys I can't
said she was so excited for Jordan get
out was her favorite movie of last year
it was awesome to see get out and him
especially but get out also as a movie
get recognized because that was one of
those movies where like people didn't
exactly know is it a [ __ ] a comedy
what is it and it got nominated for Best
Picture didn't win but Jordan still
getting recognized was like overall the
Oscars this year were so fair I think
that the distribution of all the
different awards all the different
presenters I think it was the best
they've done in years no I agree for
sure and you know I think Jordan winning
it said send a shout message especially
because the genre get out is a horror
film you know he was also spotted at
jay-z party sippin on ace of spade
champagne jay-z okay you know the party
also featured a casino for guests and
also get this you guys this is the best
part the guests were offered socks and
slippers in case they wanted to take off
their shoes after a long pizza delivered
there as well midnight
yeah and some of the other people on the
guest list of course Drake shonda rhimes
dj khaled heard uh sure Angela Bassett
casual I also love that you know
considering Tiffany and Drake were
people that be on set people were
speculating Beyonce was called them out
in her song there was Tom again so I
guess it's all good they mention it was
for mary j blige in honor of her two
Oscar nominations we actually talked her
on the red carpet right before the
Oscars about the big night
oh wow she said she was basically
telling us that like her fam is really
turning out and showing their support
for her and all the love and she said
she would immediately do it right back
so Beyonce get your Oscar nomination and
mary j blige has got your back
yes damn supporting fam yes another
afterparty was of course the Elton
John's viewing party and Miley Cyrus and
Liam Hemsworth returned there they've
not been to that party you guys since
they broke up in 2012 but they've been a
ton they won in 2010 2012 forward six
years they were there again miley
looking ravishing in this Moschino dress
it's pink it's silver it's glittery and
then she switched into a pro-ball grande
gone for the Vanity Fair party I love
that dress
how magical do they look here Ryan I
know you love Miley so are you losing
losing it I mean she looked incredible
she had her ring on full display in a
lot of the photos last night and I'm
such a fan of these two I'm so happy to
move out the way back they just look so
glamorous so glamorous Hollywood glam
what I also love about it is that again
it's like sometimes the stories in
Hollywood that are the best stories are
not the ones in the movies they're the
real-life ones who would have thought a
couple years ago that Miley lien would
be back together at that Oscars party
yet again
even since they got back together it's
been a while since we've seen them
actually posed together on a red carpet
they've gone to events together we've
seen them inside but this is such a
monumental moment for for them in their
relationship really what a fun time
waiting for that wedding invite to that
wedding honey Liam I love that Ashlee
saying love that Liam and Miley are in
public now we needed them we needed to
see them I'm gonna frame that photo for
my desk okay okay we're still only
scratching the surface there's gonna be
so much more coverage tonight on
Entertainment Tonight check your local
listings we're taking you inside all of
these after parties and more of what you
didn't see on TV also about how rowdy
people got out the Oscar so make sure
you tune in to that and of course all
this coverage is live now on ET
online.com the fashion the after parties
the speeches a lot of fun stuff up there
you guys so thank you so much for
watching thank you guys for the help
coffee tea short season thank you guys
for watching and we'll be back tomorrow
like normal for the daily Denny's so
thank you guys if you like this video
like comment and share you know the deal
alright guys we're gonna go take a nap
bye all
[Music]
you